MAIN MAN BETWEEN THE PIPES
DOWN AT CENTER ICE BY MOTTE.
>> Randy: NOW DAHLEN, NICE PLAY
IN NEU HE
SCORES
BROCK BOESER WITH KED ONE AND GS
OFF THE GLOVE OFA GOAL
AGAINST.
WHEN YOU GET TIRED, THEY'RE
TALK TO
THE NET.
DAHLEN WAS LURKING
MEIER TO
HERTL BEHIND THE NET, TO
KARLSSON
GETS BLOCKED AND THE
NIETO AND FIRED IN B Bret: ADIND
PERIODER LOOKS THAN THAT ONE,
HERTL, PRESSURED BY JUULSEN.
KARLSSON TO COUTUR IN THE MIDDLE
OVER TO WITH IT.
PEARSON WAS THERE.
BOESER OFF THE
ADIN HILL COULD HAVE FIRED
EARLIER BULSSON.
AND ERIK KARLSSON WILLA TURNOVER
ADIN HILL KEEPING THIS GAME 3-
MILLER LOST HIS EDGE
PUCK COMES BAC TANNER PEARSON PD
IN FRONT O TO PLAY
CANU
FIRED LF, AROUND THE
DEFENDERS.
I LOVE HE'S TRYING TO FIND A HER
AS PEDERSON PUT THE SHARKS HAD,
BEAUTIFUL SHOT FRO PEDERSON ANDT
BY KARLSSON.
SENDS MEIER DOWN
HERE COMES TIMO MEIER.
HE HAD THE GOAL
GOBBLED UP BY JT LITTLE DEEP
IN HIS NET AND MILLER MAKES HIM
PAY.
BLOWS IT RIGHT BY HIM OVER TL H.
>> Bret: THAT'S A BIG STOP
GIVE YOURSEL
CANUCK LINE. YEAR.
WITH JUST A HAIR OVER A MINUTE
TO GO,